women definitely need to be held
accountable definitely because I do
think like Tate said we are the ones
creating the problems for each other
because if you're opening your legs to
any man now then they don't even feel
the need to get married anymore because
they're like well I can just get sex
like it's so easy however but what I'm
just trying to say is we can't just put
it on the women because these medals the
one sleeping with them for 50 for 50
years we have put it on the man okay
there's a lot of little things in
society you guys probably don't even
notice and I didn't either before I
started like really listening to what
men say like if you say she got knocked
up it sounds like something that
happened to her not a choice she made
who knocked her up he did we always put
the blame on the man it's it's very new
this is a new type of content where you
put any accountability on women